[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de France 24 las
aplicaciones de citas encierran
múltiples tipos de vulneraciones a los
derechos de las mujeres según un estudio
de la Federación de mujeres jóvenes una
de cada cinco ha sufrido violencia
sexual derivada de estas plataformas
además hay un gran porcentaje que
asegura haberse sentido insultada o
presionada por los hombres que ha
conocido por aplicaciones como tinder
los peligros en este entorno digital
revelan múltiples pendientes que tienen
las autoridades y las propias empresas
dueñas de estas apps para mayores
garantías de seguridad Manuela Cano
realizó el informe
las aplicaciones de citas otros espacios
inseguros para las mujeres un informe de
la Federación de mujeres jóvenes delata
las profundas prácticas violentas que
atraviesan las mujeres en estas
plataformas una de estas aplicaciones
tinder encierra diversas de estas
prácticas violentas según la encuesta
que abarca a 963 mujeres heterosexuales
entre los 18 y 35 años la violencia
sexual contra las mujeres ha adquirido
nuevas formas en los espacios virtuales
de citas haciendo que los tradicionales
modus operandi de seducción patriarcal
donde se ubica la violencia sexual se
acoplen y se rearmen la organización
muestra que un veintiún,7% de estas
mujeres fueron forzadas a tener una
relación sexual mediante violencia
explícita incluso antes de los
encuentros presenciales más del 80% de
las mujeres dijeron sentirse incómodas
con los mensajes que recibieron en estas
plataformas y más del 60% recibieron
insultos o faltas de respeto todos estos
factores crean una percepción de
inseguridad
61% de las mujeres creen que las citas
con usuarios de tinder tienen mayores
riesgos que aquellas con las personas
conocidas de manera presencial ante la
falta de garantías de las propias
plataformas expertas en el tema hacen
varios tipos de recomendaciones
fotos Hasta que estemos 100% seguras de
la otra persona no porque estoy mal y en
el caso Les compartamos siempre
recomendamos ciertas tips como de
seguros en este caso de por ejemplo no
Mostrar nuestro rostro
no le brindemos cierto información
personal al inicio de la conversación es
decir cuál es mi ubicación de trabajo en
qué Distrito vivo Cuál es mi dirección
también hacemos las recomendaciones de
si quedamos en una cita con la persona
que estamos conduciendo le compartamos
nuestra ubicación a algún amigo amiga o
persona de confianza
no la problemática encierra una profunda
falta de visibilidad con pendientes
sobre el que ya hace neco diversos
movimientos feministas creo que tenemos
como dos pasos previos no que la
ciudadanía en general entendamos las
dinámicas y el funcionamiento de la
tecnología como tal porque son muchas
brechas digitales aún pero también que
las autoridades
entiendan Cómo funciona la tecnología y
si le hablamos de aplicaciones de citas
con la estigmatización que mencionaba al
inicio va a ser un poco más difícil
mayor regulación de las plataformas
acabar con la estigmatización del uso de
estas aplicaciones y un mayor compromiso
de las autoridades y la sociedad civil
son muchos de los faltantes para que el
entorno digital pueda convertirse en un
espacio seguro para las mujeres
vamos a la conversación sobre este tema
para ello la invitada es Ada Santana
ella es abogada y es presidenta de la
federación o mujeres jóvenes en España
quien precisamente hizo parte de esta
investigación y nos va a aclarar estas
dinámicas violentas que evidenciamos
todos los días en las aplicaciones de
citas Ada bienvenida a ellas hoy Hola
qué tal es innegable que las redes
sociales son un lugar para establecer
relaciones afectivas y sexuales cada vez
más habitualmente y especialmente entre
la población joven Entonces cómo esta
dinámica se ha transformado en una que
no tiene control de que no tiene
fiscalización es muy difícil saber lo
que pasa en estas aplicaciones y mucho
más difícil identificar las violencias y
llevarlas a la justicia
totalmente efectivamente las dinámicas
digamos de conocer a personas de
mantener relaciones afectivas ha
cambiado te ha transformado de ese
encuentro presencial a digamos que un
primer encuentro a través de de las
redes sociales en este caso la
investigación se centra en tinder por
ser la aplicación que más utilizan los y
las jóvenes en España también en
muchísimos países es la aplicación con
con mayor número de usuarios sobre todo
de personas jóvenes y en este sentido
nos parece Interesante como esa
violencia es machista Y esa violencia
sexuales que se reproducen también por
supuesto presencialmente se han
trasladado en este caso a este tipo de
aplicaciones de citas en un espacio que
aunque Es verdad que hemos conquistado
como es el espacio digital hemos
conquistado tecnológicamente y hemos
conquistado digitalmente la realidad es
que todavía no hay un marco jurídico que
digamos que compare que nos dé seguridad
a las personas que que digamos que somos
usuarias de estas aplicaciones que no
hay nada de malo en en digamos en
relacionarnos a través de estas
aplicaciones Pero es verdad que todavía
digamos que los avances en materia de
seguridad son muy limitados y factores
Como por ejemplo el anonimato en este
caso son claves porque los agresores
actúan desde la impunidad de saber que
pues esas agresiones que que ocurren
luego en esos encuentros presenciales o
incluso esos mensajes También violentos
que se producen en la en la propia
aplicación no van a tener una
persecución y nunca van a ser juzgados y
por eso pues actúan Desde esa anonimato
bueno además es que hay que agregar otro
elemento aquí y es que las aplicaciones
de citas se han vuelto muy famosas
porque ya ni siquiera se tratan muchas
ocasiones de tener citas sino de
mantener encuentros sexuales lo cual en
principio pues no está no está mal no
cada persona decide Cómo lleva su vida
sexual activa o no el problema es que
nos inmediatamente a un ámbito que pasa
del anonimato a lo privado no que no da
la posibilidad de que haya una
exposición de que me vean con esta
persona en la calle o de que entiendan
Qué tipo de relación estamos
desarrollando y traer las cosas a una
sexualidad que además no es una
sexualidad sana como lo dice el estudio
que ustedes realizaron pues se
representa una situación de peligro
entonces quisiera nada que nos hablara
acerca de esas banderas rojas que
deberíamos detectar con mucho más ahínco
a la hora de utilizar estas aplicaciones
y yo le pongo o le recuerdo más bien un
ejemplo que usted puso en la
investigación Y es que muchas personas o
muchos hombres llegan directamente a
buscar sexo violento
claro uno de los grandes peligros que
tienen este caso el uso de este tipo de
aplicaciones es que digamos que hay una
mayoría que utiliza la aplicación
directamente para quedar y mantener una
una relación sexual lo cual no es nada
malo no tiene ningún problema pero sí es
verdad que tenemos que tener en cuenta
que no sabemos realmente con Qué
personas estamos hablando porque al
final los sistemas de identificación de
estas aplicaciones pues son bastante
limitados y con facilidad digamos que la
persona digamos que lo que marca porque
cada persona a la hora de integrarse de
este tipo de aplicaciones pues hace un
perfil pero claro muchas veces hablamos
de perfiles ficticios es decir
perfectamente un hombre a lo mejor de 50
años pues puede decir que la aplicación
tiene 25 y evidentemente pues a lo mejor
yo que soy joven pues obviamente no
quedaría con un señor de 50 años pero de
repente me encuentro ya en ese encuentro
presencial Pues esa esa sorpresa o
incluso Más allá de la edad porque
aunque no mientan el perfil Pues sí
puede ser que luego esa persona pues sea
violenta porque no la conozco y no he
tenido la posibilidad de tener un
encuentro si es verdad que nosotras Pues
recomendaríamos que que antes hiciera un
encuentro previo en un lugar público
pues para asegurarnos que que es la
persona adecuada o que es la persona que
esperábamos encontrarnos pero si nos
parece muy necesario poner el foco en
ellos no y que no se nos vuelva como
siempre se nos dice a nosotras que que
seamos las que nos cuidemos y realmente
lo que estamos viendo Es que los
violentos son ellos por tanto nos parece
que el foco de las políticas de
prevención y de sensibilización se deben
de poner en ellos y sobre todo algo que
que debes de actuarse con emergencia por
parte de todas las instituciones es que
vemos como el marco de referencia de de
estas relaciones es cada vez más
influyente el de la pornografía que no
deja de ser un marco violento donde no
existe el consentimiento donde el único
deseo que existe es el deseo sexual
masculino y nos parece muy importante
enfatizar en la falta de educación
sexual que tienen las nuevas
generaciones y sobre como la pornografía
cada vez que es un marco re insisto
violento pues está en el día a día de de
ellos y de ella que tienen las nuevas
generaciones y las anteriores es que
simplemente no tuvieron ahora sobre este
tema Nosotros somos las primeras en no
entender la gravedad de los abusos de
poder que se pueden presentar entonces
me llama mucho la atención que la
mayoría de mujeres encuestadas dijeron
que no sintieron que fueran Víctimas de
violencia sexual pero luego en preguntas
específicas decían cosas como me sentí
forzada tener sexo o me tocaron de
manera indebida o Bueno cualquier
cantidad de situaciones de violencia
física explícita Entonces no sabemos
identificar cuando se está ejerciendo
violencia contra nosotras
Exacto uno de los grandes problemas que
tenemos es que no identificamos
realmente la violencia sexual tenemos
realmente en el imaginario colectivo de
lo que es una agresión de lo que es una
violación seguimos pensando que Que
bueno que es una realidad muy limitada
que no nos va a pasar a nosotras que que
eso que nos pasó pues bueno fue incómodo
pero no fue una agresión y realmente
efectivamente en este estudio cuando le
preguntábamos a Pues a las chicas que
que habían sido encuestadas de 18 a 35
años alguna vez habían sufrido alguna
agresión sexual a través de estas
aplicaciones o algún tipo de violencia
machista ellas nos respondían que no
pero luego cuando les preguntábamos pues
una serie de supuestos la gran mayoría
nos reconocía que en esos encuentros o
bien a través de esas aplicaciones Pues
sí que lo sí que lo habían sufrido y sí
que lo habían padecido y es curioso como
ellas pues no lo identifican y aquí pues
hay dos factores clave el primero el no
querer identificarse como como víctima y
el no querer hacer por toda las
consecuencias que tiene a nivel social y
como la sociedad Luego encima enfatiza
más en la víctima que que en el agresor
y también en cómo pues reitero la falta
de educación sexual nos ha limitado a un
imaginario muy reducido de lo que es la
violencia sexual cuando realmente
estamos viendo que es un abanico mucho
más amplio y que desgraciadamente pues
la gran mayoría de nosotras de las
jóvenes algún momento ha sufrido algún
tipo de violencia bueno y Aquí el
problema ni siquiera es Buscar un
compañero o una compañera para tener un
rato duradero o no de diversión o en la
utilización de una aplicación o de una
red social Aquí el problema es la
percepción de la sexualidad no y es que
estas aplicaciones se han vuelto el
caldo de cultivo perfecto para seguir
perpetuando los estereotipos de poder en
las relaciones sexuales como usted lo
decía de la pornografía entonces una
sexualidad en la que el hombre goza del
Poder del dominio y de de la capacidad
de maltrato frente a una mujer
los estereotipan algunos participantes
masculinos expresaron que buscaban
mujeres tranquilas hacer risueñas que
fueron unas princesas cosa que pues no
se aproxima la realidad Porque eso no
somos las mujeres no pero entonces al
entrar en esta dinámica Pues estamos
perpetuando estos estereotipos que nadie
puede fiscalizar Usted qué opina de eso
Totalmente la verdad que en este caso es
un poco frustrante ver cómo los espacios
digitales lejos de estar sirviendo para
para seguir encaminándonos a la
radicación de de los estereotipos y
roles de género todo lo contrario lo que
está es ir viendo para que sigan
aumentando para que sigan proliferando y
al final muchos de los hombres lo
utilicen como un catálogo no como un
catálogo imaginario donde ellos pues
quieren encontrar ese ideal de mujer y
vemos como ese ideal de mujer pues una
mujer que compagina tanto los roles de
género más tradicionales más de la mujer
tradicional de toda la vida ese
imaginario que tenemos todas en la
cabeza y luego por todo lo contrario esa
mujer hipersexualizada con un modelo
reproducido precisamente de la
pornografía y ese es el perfil que ellos
pues buscan en este caso a través de la
aplicación de tinder y es un poco lo que
ellos ponen como como preferencia
pero que no es realidad muchas gracias a
ustedes a Santana abogada presidenta
además de la Federación de mujeres
jóvenes en España quien ha puesto para
nosotros esta investigación para pensar
y empezar a actuar diferente Muchas
gracias a usted
Muchas gracias a nuestros televidentes
sigan con nosotros en France 24 y nos
vemos Próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]